President Trump is wrapping up his
high-stakes visit to China with more
talks between the world's two US two
strongest economic powers he received a
formal welcome overnight at the Great
Hall of the People in Beijing than in a
speech the president called America's
trade relationship with China one-sided
and unfair but the president also said
quote I don't blame China for taking
advantage of past US administrations
well that's a switch from last year's
campaign when he routinely attacked
China's trade policy president called on
China to act faster against North Korea
he also said the US and China will not
repeat failed approaches to dealing with
Kim Jong Un's regime major Garrett is
traveling with the president he joins us
now from Beijing major good morning good
morning Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
said for the first time China has
provided new intelligence on sanctions
against North Korea revealing it is not
only touching its meager commercial
sector but also beginning to crimp perks
enjoyed by North Korean military elite
Chinese president Gigi ping flattered
the president with an elaborate
welcoming ceremony and in private urged
the commander-in-chief to give these
sanctions more time to work before the
Great Hall of the People Chinese
president Gigi paying welcomed president
Trump with what he likes best a military
performance a short jaunt past a brass
band led the two leaders to a carefully
arrayed group of children leaping and
waving plastic flower bouquets on cue
moments later the president called the
pageantry magnificent possibly a global
phenomenon and the world was watching
I've already had people calling from all
parts of the world they were all
watching on the pressing issue North
Korea the president said she can take
the lead and I am calling on China and
your great president to hopefully work
on it very hard in their private
conversations on North Korea mr. Trump
told gee the global leadership role
China seeks runs through North Korea but
time is quickly running out
we must act fast the president also
pressed the issue of trade reminding ji
that all 15 of the largest u.s. annual
trade deficits have been with one
country China but I don't blame China
after all who can blame a country for
being able to take advantage of another
country for the benefit of its citizens
during the presidential campaign China
was one of mr. Trump's favorite villains
we can't continue to allow China to rape
our country
he struck a much different tone with his
feet firmly planted on Chinese soil my
feeling toward you is an incredibly warm
one as we said there's great chemistry I
want to thank you again you're a very
special man for your gracious
hospitality during the president's visit
China announced more than 250 billion
dollars in deals with US companies now
many of these agreements were in the
works long before the president arrived
and will do little to erode the barriers
to goods and services from the United
States China stubbornly maintains
tomorrow the president heads for Vietnam
in an expected meeting with Russian
President Vladimir Putin the Kremlin
said the probability of such an
encounter was quote quite high but
Tillerson here was non-committal saying
Nora it is still under consideration all
right major Garrett in Beijing thank you
so much